[Musique]
la dynastie des ebooks
nous retrouvons la belle n'a dit ni muke
son berger allemand en bolivie
péruvienne et des répétitions seront
lents et vendeville et eisel aut à la
haye les lots plus dépouillés eva
mi-mars a fait dix fois qu'on fait la
même chanson bis matin l'émoi de bons à
rien de dire que c'est seulement qu'il a
la peau de vous connaître à la brillante
bolivie souhaitait commandant de bord
dit tu te barres bis je sais que je te
la piste du copain bull ont été
coupables on regarde un peu derrière et
à la couleur question ses compagnons
allait vraiment la petite je déteste
thématiques qu'elle ne peut pas aller
contre la nature
eva muller a plus que toi mais l'air il
à müller - nadine ebooks m'appeler va
muller dans quelqu'un m'a dit donc je
les basanés
je retourne chez mon père le pass lui
accablé revient les mains vides chez le
roi des ebooks qui es-tu un bel étranger
je suis le prince lui le promis de
nadine amouk la princesse que j'ai
rencontré il ya presqu'un an tiens ya
presque un an en septembre
je suis tombé follement amoureux d'elle
tout de suite j'ai été voir son père j
du monseigneur donnez moi la main de
votre fille à l'époque les besoins de
boudin blanc parce que l'approché des
fêtes de noël on arrive à envoyer à
jérusalem pour chercher du boudin blanc
l'a battue me bloque à bernis qualo rien
du tout par contre j'ai rencontré kassim
kim accompli aïcha mais j'en ai eu
ras-le-bol
parce que c'est pas vous que le raconter
mais les femmes au bout d'un moment
alors naji elle a été enlevée pour le
risque a tort
j'avais perdu sa trajectoire fall et le
ps 14 ans voulait plus on la retrouve à
l'afrique juste envie je peux pas tout
vous raconter
oui c'est guy les leurs augmenter son
choix dites moi c'est c'est tout droit
vous prenez tout droit puis après c'est
sur la gauche juste après les cabinets
voilà
c'est marrant je pensais pas que le roi
a été aussi remarqué ça réconforte
on sent moins seul
mais si au nom il manquait plus que
celui là
[Musique]